السياسه للاسف غير مغلفه دائما بالنوايا
الحسنه فقط قد يكون هناك نوايا حسنا
لمساعده الشعوب الاخرى ولكن هناك اتهامات
شخصيه فيها تحقيقات قضائيه كبرى على في
الداخل الفرنسي ضد الرئيس ساركوزي بتلقي
اموال من زعيم دوله اجنبيه ولذلك اراد
التخلص منه ما كان موقفك شخصيا من ذلك
ولكن ما اقوله ان العداله الفرنسيه تنظر
في هذه القضيه ولننتظر ما ستقوله في هذه
القضيه بالنظر الى مختلف الشهود ومختلف
القضاه الذين احيانا ما يناقضون بعضهم
ليست لدي معلومات كافيه لكي ادلي برايي في
هذه النقطه لما اكون مطلعه على هذا الملف
ولا اعتقد انه يعود لي ان اقول ان كان هذا
صحيحا ام لاحيا لا ان اجهله
في يعني العمل الحكومي مباشره انا ذاك
ولكنك سياسيه فرنسيه مخضرامه ولذلك نسالك
عن بعض هذه الامور ومنها ان ساركوزي
[موسيقى]
طبعا ارى انه من الطبيعي ان تطرح علي هذه
الاسئله ولكن هناك تقاليد ولا تنسى انني
كنت وزيره للعدل وبحسب التقاليد يجب عدم
التحدث عن قضيه لا تزال قيدا النظر امام
القضاء وما اقوله مبدئيا هو ان هناك شهودا
لا يدلون باقوال في الاتجاه ذاته وهناك
افادات نيكولاصه التي يجب اخذها في
الاعتبار وبما ان القضيه لا تزال عالقه
امام القضاء سننتظر الحكم